foreign
brings to the world of fiction from
Simply harnessing The Power of Elements
to having destructive magical power
capable of changing reality every new
anime series these days brings about a
totally new kind of ability for fans to
discuss and debate upon while some of
these abilities may be generic others
are outright broken abilities that seem
too much to be possessed by even a
fictional character but don't we all
love watching the flashy display of
special ability into climactic moments
well here are the top 10 most
overpowered anime abilities from the
year 2020 to 2023 let's start with show
kusakabe's severed universe
foreign
[Music]
force is a universe stacked with strong
fire abilities but as of now none come
close to show severed Universe well in
the anime at the very least using this
ability allows him to stop all Motion in
the area around him while he himself
moves at a normal speed which to others
looks like he moved faster than the
speed of light one of the instances
where show displays major use of
disability is his battle against his
brother Shinra kusagabe they both fight
it out with Shinra using his technique
rapid to move at the speed of light
while shows using his seven Universe
this ability makes show nearly
Invincible it makes it look like he
stopped time that isn't really the case
here he does this by rapidly stealing
heat from the universe calling it down
causing the natural expansion of the
universe and as a result he's able to
just slow down time though he can only
use this ability for a short period of
time because the cold affects him as
well
still one of the most broken abilities
to exist if done right and if he finds a
way to counter his limitations so could
virtually be the fastest being in the
series
foreign
before we continue have you ever
wondered how it would feel to play one
of the best manwa out there well you're
lucky to have today's sponsor based on
the globally successful webtoon Tower of
God the webtoon sensation Tower of God
is now a thrilling epic anime RPG with
high quality full 3D animation graphics
and complete with all of the original
characters Tower of God new world is a
3D mobile game and its gameplay
highlights team building and strategy
where you combine different characters
and synergize their roles to demolish
every opponent that comes your way of
course it has to follow the story of
tower of God but it doesn't end there as
it has side stories that expand the
current universe of the series and don't
worry if you haven't read the webtoon or
watch the anime you can still have a lot
of fun because they introduce you to the
story when you play the game for the
first time so you're definitely not
going to get confused if you download
the game now you'll also get to enjoy
their Summer Festival event new updates
like characters such as SSR plus viol
and SSR Shia Shia are coming along with
costumes and new summer story missions
and rewards that you just can't miss so
what are you waiting for download Tower
of God new world through the link in the
description now let's continue with the
video
[Music]
with probably one of the most recent
displays of power in anime we have quite
literally the most broken ability in
Bleach Grammy's Visionary Grammy is one
of yuha's sternwritters and it's called
the Visionary his ability allows him to
manifest anything he imagines into
existence even to the point where he has
the power to manipulate life seeing as
when he imagined himself dying and he
was about to die because of that he
could also manifest material things out
of thin air like how he pulled out
dozens and dozens of guns and
miraculously stopped zaragi from cutting
him even for a moment which is an
amazing feat in itself not only that but
he could also Imagine himself instantly
healing becoming stronger making a clone
and even throwing a massive Meteo at
Zaraki however his abilities do come
with limitations which show just how
crazy his imagination can be and he
definitely isn't one of the smarter
characters in Bleach if his ability was
to be used by someone like Eisen well
let's just say bleach would have never
even started there's no ability more
broken than his because his imagination
is literally the limit which is why when
he failed to imagine a body that could
hold zaraki's strength you couldn't help
us slap your forehead
I
um
[Music]
up next we have the dark Edge Lord
himself Shadow the main character of
eminence in Shadow the series first
looked like a normal issakai but after
its release quickly caught a lot of
popularity becoming one of the top
contenders of its season the show's
crowning moment is Shadow's ultimate
attack I am Atomic the very first time
Shadow used this technique was in his
fight against Xenon the fight was
already one-sided but being the edge
Lord he is Shadow released his most
powerful ability to completely overwhelm
his foe to use this attack Shadow
gathers all the magical power he can
muster and condenses it into his weapon
now once the weapon strikes its Target a
comparable amount of power equal to a
nuclear explosion is released
eradicating everything in his
environment this attack essentially
makes him become a nuclear weapon that
even affects space itself there's no
radiation and it can even make a barrier
where the once inside it won't be
affected not only that this ability has
a lot of variations from making it heal
people in a certain radius or he can use
it to transform his sword into Nine
Dragons this over-the-top Display of
Power with the chilling voice acting and
animation sequence has gone at not a
hype for this series
foreign
have a villain that has one of the most
despicable quirks in mha shigaraki's
awakened decay in the battle between
Heroes and paranormal Liberation Front
currently going on shigaraki despite
being unable to complete his
modification entirely was able to awaken
his Quirk with a loose wire making
contact with the fluid he was brewing in
shigaraki was fully woken back up
without even really trying shigaraki
Decay is not only the hospital but the
immediate area around it as well soon
turning everything into chaos the nearby
cities were also caught in the range and
many lives were lost in this act
awakened Decay lifted all previous
restrictions on his Quirk the day Decay
first manifested it was only capable of
turning a house to dust in a few minutes
once an adult shigaraki restored its
true power it even reached greater
height being able to level entire cities
in a few moments decaying anything that
happened to be in the vicinity now
shigaraki doesn't even need to touch his
targets he can just place his hand on
the ground and everything turns to dust
it can also control Decay to a point
where certain targets won't be affected
it's a deadly Quirk well suited for the
now main antagonist of the series
foreign
this has got to be one of the most
anticipated fights of this season in the
final showdown of Luffy versus kaido
after being defeated by kaido for the
third time Luffy manages to awaken his
gomugomunomi achieving gear 5. this
strengthens his rubbery body and allows
him to manipulate and transform his
environment as he pleases Luffy's
already rubbery body gains freedom and
flexibility that surpasses what he would
receive from any of his previous forms
you can say it's the peak of Luffy's
power he's now able to fight with as
much creativity as he possibly can
further in his fight against kaido
Luffy's seemed to be able to easily
manipulate the size of his body without
even using any air he can take direct
hits from kaido's bolo breath and it
didn't even deal too much damage at his
best he can turn himself into a giant if
he even showed the ability to turn
everything he touches into rubber which
helps him fight with even more freedom
to the point where he grabbed a
lightning bolt and threw it at kaido
this power-up turned Luffy into one of
the most ridiculously overpowered
characters and if he Masters it will
almost entirely be Invincible in this
form
genies
[Music]
can't eat scale
moving up we have another overpowered
time-related ability it's bacoli's time
slash during the large-scale Battle of
humans Vs monsters in the Underworld one
of the main threats to humans was the
appearance of vector emperor of the dark
territory bacoli goes to face Vector but
gets completely overwhelmed during this
fight being unable to do anything he
sits there waiting for his demise but
his Dragon partner comes along and
distracts Vector for a single moment
which gives bacoli enough time to use
his ability time slash with the time
piercing sword by using this ability
Bugatti is able to slice the past of
someone bringing about instant death on
his Target this overpowered ability
plays a huge role in how the story
progressed defeating Emperor Victor
couldn't have been an easy task for
anyone else not to mention Vector had
nearly infinite health the time slash
completely drained his durability
erasing him from existence as with one
attack he didn't even exist in the first
place not only that but this attack can
also twice the future as it has the
properties of the system clock that can
interfere with time in the Underworld
server this was surely one of the best
executed fights in all of Sword Art
Online from the sharp animation to
beautiful choreography And the emotions
keeping it all in the Run
moving on we have remorse buildzeb up
despite having a large arson of skills
the most overpowered ultimate skill that
rumoru possesses is the gluttonous King
builds Above This skill has multiple
attributes the most important of which
are the attributes of predation and
mimic predation allows River to absorb
the target whole while mimic allows him
to use the skills and abilities of the
target absorbed rimeroot uses buildzebub
on Demon Lord Clayman during the events
of wall purges after they face off in
Mortal Kombat rimuru easily overpowers
Clayman leaving him in the hands of
Despair while claiman is laying down
contemplating his choices rimaru uses
build zip up to finally ingest him the
ability also allows rimaru to absorb the
target Soul which made clayman's Revival
obsolete some other attribute Wheels
above has is imaginary space where
rimaru has unlimited space inside of him
after he absorbs a Target he can also
use food chain where he can copy a less
effective version of his subordinate
skills and can even give skills to them
if they're compatible it's both an
attack type and support type ability
that makes rumoru one of the most
dangerous beings in tensura not to
mention this is only take one of his
many ultimate skills
[Music]
next on our list we have the famous and
well-renowned sorcerer satoru Gojo known
as the strongest Jiu Jitsu sorcerer in
the world of Jiu Jitsu Kaizen Gojo has
captured a lot of popularity with his
classic and enthusiastic personality his
character is a balance of a cold-hearted
killing machine and a caring Sensei one
of the strongest abilities is his domain
expansion he first displayed his Mastery
over his domain when he used it to
counter jogo's coffin on the Iron
Mountain ultimate void was the more
refined of the two domains an easily
suppressed confident of the Iron
Mountain once caught by the domain the
target will be sent to a place
resembling the center of the universe
where he'll be able to see and feel
everything while not being able to see
or feel anything at the same time Gojo
explains this phenomenon as the action
of perception that people take in life
being forced upon them infinitely this
is totally one of the strongest domain
expansions we've seen throughout the
series all the target could do was stare
at the void and wait as Gojo will
ruthlessly obliterate them this domain
is a sure win ability that can't be
dodged or avoided the fight was
completely one-sided it's showing an
overwhelming difference in strength
between both parties but is there a
domain that can be gojos well make sure
you stay tuned to jiu jitsu Kaizen to
find out
let's move on to poochies made in heaven
[Music]
JoJo has one of the most unique Power
Systems called stands the physical
manifestation of a person's fighting
Spirit each stand is unique and has a
distinct ability that separates them
from the others in some cases astan's
power is simple and straightforward on
the other hand there are some stars that
possess incredibly complex and Powerful
abilities the latter is the case of
Enrico Pucci's maid in heaven the
antagonist of Jojo Stone ocean Arc the
real extent of this land was witnessed
in the battle between Pucci and JoJo's
Squad where JoJo's Squad was completely
annihilated with only Emporio left alive
barely escaping made in heaven has the
ability of time acceleration which makes
it possible for him to dramatically
speed up the flow of time and also
counter abilities that function with a
time limit like Star platinum's time
stop doing this allows Pucci to move at
extraordinary speed and also speed up
the life cycle of the entire universe
effectively resetting the universe which
references Einstein's theory of
relativity if you're in a cold
environment you freeze instantly if
you're watch environment you'll burst or
end up in Flames or melt the ones who
aren't affected by this attack are only
poochie himself and God this ability is
so complex that might need to make a
whole new video just to explain how it
works no wonder it was considered by Dio
to be the ultimate stands
shut up
when talking about overpowered abilities
you can't leave out one of the strongest
anime characters to ever exist arnos
volleygold The Reincarnation of demon
king of tyranny arnos possesses many
strong abilities that push some anime
fans to consider him the strongest anime
character but the one which stands out
the most is demon sword Venus donowa
sometimes claimed as the abolisher of
reason it's a sword created by arnos
himself a slice of this sword can
destroy anything that exists no matter
how durable or infinite it may be Thanos
uses this sword in his battle against
melhes and to finally put an end to the
Clash arnos calls upon his sword and
sends a sword slash towards malheis
who's about to escape through a portal
milnheis notices the Slash and Dodges it
in time but suddenly his legs are cut
from his body as if he was still slashed
by Venus donowa this is because Venus
Donovan destroyed the reason and logic
that avoiding the attack meant dodging
it
foreign it destroys the order of the
known world including what's the right
and wrong answer on a test this scene
explicitly describes the power of Venus
donowa which can alter any laws that
stand in its way a ridiculously strong
ability for an already ridiculously
strong character
and that's it for my list of the top 10
most overpowered anime abilities but
with so many new anime airing and even
stronger characters popping up there's
bound to be some that I've missed so let
me know what you think in the comment
section below don't forget to download
Tower of God new world through the link
in the description I'll be waiting for
you in the tower I'm glad to have you
here and thank you so much again for
watching this video